also ich kann nicht fassen dass du
wirklich schön schläuche aus so eine
gehirnwäsche hell wie so schön schlau
gehirnwäsche wissenssendung der alltag
ist der wissenschaftlich hier gewaschen
du bist du bist so gehirngewaschen mehr
zu sonnig mal von post faktisch über
fake news bis hin zu alternativen fakten
in einer zeit in der es nicht leichter
sein könnte an informationen zu kommen
ist eines sicher kein fach kann jemals
so überzeugend sein dass er eine meinung
verändern könnte
nein du magst der zahlen und fahrten
haben ich hingehe ich habe eine mine
das alles mal nach einem aktuellen trend
klingen aber wissenschaftlern ist das
phänomen der unbeugsamen persönlichen
meinung schon seit jahrzehnten bekannt
stell dir vor du würdest bei einer
psychologischen studie teilnehmen man
gibt dir notizen zum lesen es handelt
sich um abschiedsbriefe die menschen vor
ihrem selbstmord geschrieben haben
sollen bei der hälfte handelt es sich um
worte echte abschiedsbriefe
die andere hälfte ist fake jetzt musst
du beweisen ob du ein guter hobby
psychologe bist und soll entscheiden
welche dieser briefe echt oder fake sind
zu diesen ersten brief teilt seine
entscheidung mit und siehe da du hast
recht übrigens in zwei im brief- und
auch das ein gutes gespür und so weiter
stellt sich heraus
du bist ein echter pro darin echte von
falschen abschiedsbriefen zu
unterscheiden sein kumpel im nebenzimmer
deren derselben studie teilnimmt hat den
trainer nicht so raus er rät fast jedes
mal falsch
aber anschließend bekommt ihr jeweils
gesagt dass alles nur inszeniert war
unabhängig davon ob du richtig oder
falsch sagt hackl die immer nur gesagt
du legst richtig und einem kumpel hat
man immer nur gesagt er sei falsch alles
also nur schein
nachdem man euch jetzt ganz klar gesagt
hat dass alles nur manipuliert war
sollte jetzt im nachhinein schießen wie
gut ihr tatsächlich geraten habt über
oder unterdurchschnittlich was denkt ihr
was jetzt passiert die teilnehmer deren
eine bessere performance vorgegaukelt
wurde schätzten sich als
überdurchschnittlich ein
die teilnehmer den versagen vorgegaukelt
wurde schätzten sich als
unterdurchschnittlich 1
in wirklichkeit schnitten beide
teilnehmergruppen gleich gut oder
schlecht ab das bedeutet wenn man sich
einmal erst mal einen eindruck oder eine
meinung gebildet hat dann hängt man
diesem alter bruder an dieser meinung
fest auch in meinen nachhinein
feststellt dass es falsch war
das ist uns völlig egal das ist nicht
die einzige studie es gibt etliche die
aufs selbe ergebnis kommen zumal sich
die eigentlich du konfirmation bei es
ist ein menschliches und sehr gut
untersuchtes phänomen konfirmation beiß
beschreibt die tatsache dass wir
informationen die unser eigenes weltbild
stützen prinzip er als glaubwürdig und
relevant betrachten während wir
informationen die nicht unser weltbild
passen ignorieren oder als quatsch abtun
eure facebook chronik ist garantiert
eine einzige konfirmation preisblase und
hier fanden wissenschaftler etwas sehr
interessantes heraus informationen die
unsere eigene meinung widersprechen
für nicht etwa dazu dass wir unsere
meinung mal überdenken neigen sie führen
als ich und allein dazu dass wir unsere
eigene meinung verhärten
das sagt euch jemand tatsächlich etwas
den ich nicht zustimmen
unerhört was die anderen bauten alles
lügner
so schallt es gleichwohl von allen
seiten als wissenschafter fragt man sich
jetzt wenn wir so irrational
sein können warum hat sich diese
eigenschaft revolutionär durchgesetzt
stellt euch vor einem haus würde nicht
glauben dass katzen gefährlich sind weil
das nur panikmache ist von den rahmen
egal wie diese von anderen katzen
gefressen werden
diese maus bliebe bei ihrer überzeugung
sie würde nicht
und der mensch forscher glauben dass
diese sehr rationale seite von uns einen
evolutionären vorteil gehabt haben muss
zu zeiten der jäger und sammler wurde
das leben bereits von sozialen
zusammenleben zusammen arbeiten zusammen
funktionieren bestimmt und die soziale
stellung des einzelnen wurde immer
wichtiger zum beispiel möchtest du nicht
dein leben beim jagen riskieren werden
die anderen in der höhle abhängen die
fähigkeit alle bei auseinandersetzungen
für sich zu gewinnen und dazu gehört
eben auch das beharren auf dem eigenen
standpunkt war manchmal wichtiger als
rationales urteilsvermögen und in zeiten
wie diesen wo wir mit fake news
überflutet werden wo rationales
urteilsvermögen das allerwichtigste wäre
hat sich unsere umwelt rundherum
schneller verändert als die evolution
mithalten kann und so kommt es dem einen
oder anderen vielleicht vor als würden
wir uns gerade wieder rückwärts bewegen
ok mai und was ist jetzt die lösung
die lösung habe ich nicht aber ich weiß
was ich immer vorwärts bewegen wird und
das ist wissenschaft und forschung die
wissenschaft heißt nämlich auf deine
meinung du kannst auf deiner meinung
beharren wie du willst so lange du keine
daten produziert die andere forscher
reproduzieren können egal ob sie deiner
meinung sind oder ob sie dich mögen
natürlich gibt es auch wissenschaftler
die betrügen und lügen solche menschen
gibt es überall lügen forscher aber das
prinzip wissenschaft ist möglicherweise
das einzige was uns vor der dummheit
retten kann meine meinung braucht ein
schön schlau ein leichtes unterhaltsames
format sein soll
ist es uns wichtig dass wir selbst im
alltag interesse an der wissenschaft
wecken damit die schlauen jungen leute
da draußen sich nicht nur für die
politik sondern auch für
naturwissenschaften interessiert
vielmehr rationales urteilsvermögen
schön schlau für dieses video habe ich
mich inspirieren lassen von den sehr
lesenswerten artikel aus dem new yorker
effekte und change mainz habe ich euch
unten verlinkt zusammen mit
wissenschaftlichen studien lassen mich
wissen was ihr denkt behalt ihr immer
auf eure meinung oder lasst ihr euch
auch mal vom gegenteil überzeugen
schreibt es mir wir sehen uns nächste
woche